G
US.
>> YOU BET, THANK YOU.
TREY: JOINING US NOW,
GEORGIA GOVERNOR BRIAN KEMP.
THANK YOU GOVERNOR.
WE'RE TWO DAYS AWAY FROM A
MAJOR MIDTERM, ELECTION,
GOVERNORSHIP ON
BALLOT, AND THE HOUSE.
THE CONGRATULATIONS TO YOU
FOR YESTERDAY'S FOOTBALL
GAME.
I WAS SURPRISED TO SEE THE
GAME PLAYED IN AUSTIN,
WASN'T THERE A MOVEMENT BY
SOME TO GET SPORTING EVENTS
OUT OF YOUR STATE, THEY
DIDN'T LIKE YOUR VOTING LAW
OR DID I DREAM THAT?
>> NO, THAT WAS THE CASE
TREY WITH MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL AFTER WE PASSED
ELECTION INTEGRITY ACT, THAT
MAKES IT EASY TO VOTE AND
HARD TO CHEAT, YOU ARE NOT
HEARING A LOT ABOUT THAT
RIGHT NOW, WE HAVE A RECORD
TURN OUT THE IN MAY PRIMARY
ON REPUBLICAN AND DEMOCRATIC
SIDE, WE HAVE RECORD TURN
OUT FOR EARLY VOTING WHICH
ENDED THIS FRIDAY, WE HAD
OVER 2 MILLION PEOPLE VOTE
IN THE STATE, IT HAS BEEN
INCREDIBLE TURN OUT, WE FEEL
GOOD ABOUT THINGS ISSUE WE
HAVE BEEN TELLING PEOPLE THE
TRUTH IN GEORGIA, STANDING
UP TO WOKE
CANCEL CULTURE INCLUDING
STACEY ABRAMS.
TREY: GOVERNOR, ONE THING TO
HAVE IT FALL APART BUT
ANOTHER THING FOR PEOPLE TO
APOLOGIZE TO THE PEOPLE IN
GEORGIA, HAS PRESIDENT BIDEN
CALLED TO APOLOGIZE?
HE REFERRED TO YOUR STATE,
USING JIM CROW LANGUAGE?
AND YET AS YOU POINT OUT
VOTER PARTICIPATION IS UP
EVEN AFTER PASSING THE BILL
THAT HE LIKENED TO JIM CROW
LAWS.
>> WHAT IS INTERESTING
-- YOU KNOW HE SAID THAT,
VICE PRESIDENT SAID THAT
WOKE CORPORATE CEOs SAID
THAT AND MAJOR
LEAGUE BASEBALL PULLED THE
ALL STORE GAME.
AND STACEY ABRAMS HAS BEEN
SAYING THAT.
FILED SUIT AGAINST THE
THE STATE.
COST TAXPAYERS 6 MILLION TO
DEFEND THAT LAWSUIT, WE SAID
THEN WAS NOT SUPPRESSIVE, WE
HAD A SYSTEM THAT WAS EASY
TO VOTE AND HARD TO CHEAT,
SHE LOST ON EVERY SINGLE
POINT IT WAS AN
OBAMA-APPOINTED FEDERAL
JUDGE THAT RULED AGAINST
HER.
UNDER THIS THE LEGISLATION
WE HAD THIRD LARGEST VOTER
TURN OUT FOR EARLY VOTING IN
STATE'S HISTORY, DO YOU KNOW
WHAT OTHER 24 WERE THAT IS
2018 AND 2020,.
I WAS SECRETARY OF STATE,
LEADING UP TO 2018 ELECTION.
IT IS EASY TO VOTE AND HARD
TO CHEAT ETHEY NEVER TALK
ABOUT SENATE BILL 20 2, WE
ADDED DAYS FOR PEOPLE TO BE
ABLE TO VOTE ON WEEKENDS, WE
MORE PUNE
OPPORTUNITIES NOW, YOU DON'T
HEAR ABOUT LONG LINES AND
PEOPLE NEEDING FOOD AND
WATER IN LINES BECAUSE WHOLE
PROBLEM THAT WE WANT TO FIX,
YOU SHOULDN'T BE IN LINE
LONG ENOUGH TO NEED FOOD OR
WATER, YOU CAN STILL GET,
BUT THAT IS THE YOU KNOW
THEY MADE THE BIG ARGUMENT
THAT ARE NOT TRUE OUR
LEGISLATION WAS GOOD.
AND THAT IS WHAT PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND.
THEY KNOW WE HAVE
FIGHTING FOR THEM.
DEMOCRATS' ELECTION
INTEGRITY LIKE THE
REPUBLICANS DO.
AND HAVING BEEN GET THROUGH
40 YEAR HIGH JOE BIDEN
INFLATION AND GAS PRICES AND
CUTTING TAXES ON PEOPLE IN
GEORGIA UNLIKE PRESIDENT
BIDEN WHO PROMISED TO NOT
RAISE THE TAXES DID THIS.
TREY: GOVERNOR THERE WAS A
CLIP, I WON'T PLAY IT IN
INTEREST OF TIME, THERE WAS
A CLIP, YOUR OPPONENT KIND
OF SUGGESTED ONLY WAY SHE
COULD LOSE IS BECAUSE OF
VOTER SUPPRESSION, HER
VOTERS WILL NOT GET TO
POLLS, THE MEDIA GETS APP
S -- GETS -- IT SOUNDS LIKE
SOMEONE LOOKING FOR A
SCAPEGOAT.
>> I AM NOT TOO FOCUSED ON
WHAT SHE HAS BEEN SAYING IN
REGARDS TO THE UPCOMING
ELECTION, I AM CONFIDENT IN
THE PROCESS, I WILL STAND BY
THE RESULTS, WE HAVE TO GET
OUR PEOPLE OUT TO PUSH BACK
AGAINST THINGS SHE HAS SAID.
EVEN OUTSIDE OF THIS
ELECTION LIKE, SHE IS
WILLING TO DEFEND POLICE,
AND BELIEVES IN ELIMINATING
CASH BAIL, TO YOUR POINTS
EARLIER, YOU KNOW SHE STILL
SITTING ON BOARD OF
ORGANIZATIONS THAT IS
RAISING MONEY AND GIVING
GRANTS OUT TO DEFUND THE
POLICE, THE MARGARET KACIE
FOUNDATION, SHE CRITICIZED
MY FOR KEEPING OUR ECONOMY
OPEN, AND GETTING OUR KIDS
BACK IN THE CLASSROOM AS
WELL.
TREY: GOVERNOR BRIAN KEMP,
WE'LL BE WATCHING TUESDAY
NIGHT, THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US AGAIN ON A SUNDAY NIGHT,
LOOK FORWARD TO VISIT